bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 4 septembre manifestation au
pluriel contre le projet d'une deuxième
loi sur les 35 heures c'est trop ou pas
assez trop pour les patrons qui étaient
des milliers à dénoncer l'erreur du
gouvernement
c'était pas assez à l'appel de la cgt
ils étaient d'autres milliers a demandé
une loi plus volontariste en autriche
l'extrême droite populiste progresse
plus d'un quart des électeurs autrichien
se prononce en sa faveur
l'armée russe avant sans territoire
tchétchène c'est tout le caucase qui en
subit les conséquences nous vous
proposerons un document sur un village
sous les bombes au daguestan le peintre
bernard buffet s'est donné la mort il
était âgé de 71 ans il vivait retiré à
tout retour dans le var memphis los
angeles la nouvelle orléans ce sont les
étapes des nouvelles aventures d'eddy
mitchell que l'on retrouve dans un
nouvel album glitch elle est ce soir
notre invité à la veille du débat
parlementaire sur les 35 heures c'est
dans la rue et au palais des sports de
la porte de versailles à paris que des
rumeurs contradictoires se faisait
entendre aujourd'hui tout d'abord ceux
venus des rangs patronaux on dit
maintenant pour être plus correct issus
des milieux des entrepreneurs au moins
vingt mille peut être plus selon medef
ont usé des sifflets des mots de
démission à l'égard de madame aubry pour
le dire que sa loi était une erreur et
qu'ils entendaient qu'on respecte leur
liberté reportage en pole chapelle et
joseph baltique
ils sont venus de toute la france pour
dire leur colère contre la loi aubry
un rassemblement qui avait des allures
de meeting politique le parti des
entrepreneurs a trouvé son tryba ernest
antoine seillière a clamé aujourd'hui
par près de 20000 patron qui assure la
place de la france en europe et dans le
monde
madame aubry
vous nous ignorer depuis que vous avez
pris vos fonctions vous avez tort vous
pensez que nous ne comptons pas eh bien
venez ne comptait aujourd'hui si vous
avez cru nous diviser voyez notre unité
vous avez voulu distinguer les bons
élèves des prétendus mauvais voyez notre
unanimité
je reconnais c'est l'échec de votre
première loi qui a tiré à peine 1 % des
entreprises
volvo loire tout le monde le sait est
une erreur
galvanisés les plus remontés réclame m
une vraie manif dans la rue
pour les autres la journée et déjà
historique en soit il faut donc
rapporter un souvenir vendu 100 francs
le tampon un symbole pour brocarder
l'administration tatillonne et archaïque
tous nos documents de l'en empêche les
loups chef d'entreprise nous n'avons
plus droit non plus de le voir
parti à la reconquête de l'opinion
publique à la veille du débat
parlementaire les patrons en surtout
accompli aujourd'hui un dernier baroud
d'honneur contre les 35
certes aujourd'hui à la date bien réelle
du 4 octobre près de 16000 entreprises
ont déjà signé pour les 35 heures mais
le medef estime que cela fait à peine 1
% des entreprises et les patrons venus
de toutes les régions de france
entendait bien reconquérir une opinion
publique plutôt favorables à la
réduction du temps de travail pour
france 2 il ya le frontier maxime
liogier ont suivi l'un des patrons
manifestants pdg d'une entreprise du
bâtiment de lyon dans sa montée sur la
capitale patron de terrain voilà l'image
que bernard fontanel
je veux donner de soi pdg d'une
entreprise de bâtiment et de travaux
publics
il emploie plus de 170 personnes avec
les 35 heures il va devoir revoir ses
effectifs modifier ses plannings un
véritable casse tête pour monter deux
équipes avec deux équipes on va
déresponsabiliser le véritable chef de
chantier
donc c'est un péché de chantier est un
personnage important
le grutier il faudra un deuxième jeu sa
deuxième recrue chez bon écoutez on n'a
jamais pratiquement mis deux pilotes
dans la même automobile mécontents
bernard fontanel s'est joint ce matin
aux autres patrons de la région rhône
alpes tous ont répondu présent à l'appel
du medef un tgv spécial a même été
affrétés pour leur départ sur paris un
train d'ailleurs bloqué pendant près
d'une heure par des manifestants
favorables 35 heures choc de cultures
sur le quai j'ai négocié la réduction du
temps de travail en 96 et le jour où on
aurait peut-être pu conclure vous
avaient envahi la salle et la discussion
était terminée
vous avez une âme et je fais confiance à
mes camarades il a raison non mais pour
perturber les réunions devant les
entrepreneurs eux ont opté pour une
autre forme d'action pas d' intervention
spectaculaire juste un grand
rassemblement national à paris dans le
secteur du bâtiment ils pensaient avoir
trouvé la solution en signant un accord
de branche
malheureusement avec le second projet de
loi sur les 35 heures toute la partie
est à rejouer nous on s'était battu pour
avoir un accord de branche et ce qui
nous révolte peut être avant tout c'est
qu'effectivement l'accord de branche que
nous avons signé en novembre au 98
madame aubry parle et je vois
disposition par la deuxième loi va rayer
d'un produit les 35 heures un dossier
qui mobilise le patronat bernard fontana
lancer quelque chose
8 qui aujourd'hui manifester seulement
pour la deuxième fois de sa vie la
première c'était en 1982 pour protester
déjà à l'époque contre l'état qui
réglemente la vie des entreprises
voilà donc pour la version trop c'est
trop la loi est une erreur face à elle
il y a les démonstrations à l'appel de
la cgt dans plusieurs villes de france
pour réclamer une meilleure application
de la loi des avancées sociales
significatives ou à voir quelques images
des défilés de toulouse lille et lyon
des rassemblement d'ampleur d'ailleurs
inégal y en a eu également à
saint-etienne et à paris avec à chaque
fois les habituels statistiques disent
pendantes entre policiers et
organisateurs à paris donc les
responsables de la cgt ont reçu deux
signes d'amitié politiques ceux de
robert hull pour le parti communiste et
de françois hollande pour le parti
socialiste cette emilie lanson et
florence griffon qui ont suivi le
cortège ne vous y trompez pas il s'est
jeté les prévenus des filets contre les
35 heures mais bientôt loi ou en à ces
conditions et bernard thibault le
secrétaire général du syndicat en pose
plus dur
en fonction des dispositions adoptées
sur les heures supplémentaires sur le
temps de travail des cadres sur
l'annualisation du temps de travail est
certaine flexibilité accepter ou pas eh
bien ce sera un texte qui sera
susceptible plus ou moins de donner lieu
à des créations d'emplois c'est donc
tout l'enjeu de notre mobilisation
aujourd'hui un enjeu d'importance
également pour le parti communiste qui
ne veut pas se laisser déborder à gauche
sur ce thème et l'envol robert hue a
fait le déplacement
cinq minutes plus tard françois hollande
a fait à son tour une apparition le
premier secrétaire du ps dans la rue
contre le projet de loi de son
gouvernement
plus subtil que ça je suis toujours
mobilisés contre le feu qui sont
hostiles aux réformes aujourd'hui ceux
qui sont hostiles de répandre ses le
patronat ne s'est pas le gardien dégage
loin de là c'est pas le gouvernement non
plus les patrons justement certains
manifestants trouvent que les 35 heures
leur sont trop favorables et l'on
manifeste parce qu'on dit que la loi
aubry ces clubs mais pour le medef une
loi pour l'envoi qui n'oblige pas la
création assure jack d'emplois mais par
contre les aides elles sont là la
manifestation soul est unitaire mais
aucune des grandes centrales syndicales
n'a répondu à l'appel sept mille
manifestants selon la police
25000 selon la cgt la lutte continue dit
elle même si c'est à l'assemblée
il faut ajouter pour ce lundi que lors
d'un déjeuner à matignon avec le premier
ministre les présidents et responsables
de la majorité plurielle ont constaté
leurs divergences les communistes sont
hostiles au projet de loi en l'état
distille les verts et le mouvement des
citoyens réclame des améliorations mais
pour madame aubry et les socialistes
l'equilibre de la loi doit demeurer
alors gérard leclerc qui allaient ceux
qui réclament qui disent que c'est trop
d'autres qui disent que c'est pas assez
c'est curieux cette double pression non
et puis dans les faits un rassemblement
de patrons face à des ouvriers qui
défilent tous à un parfum peu suranné
lutte des classes au total la vente h ce
soir est plutôt medef si l'on se base
sur le nombre de manifestants sur
l'aspect offensif des discours c'est un
peu normal les 35 heures c'est la bête
noire presque la raison d'être du medef
mais on peut se poser la question tout
ça pour quoi
1 les 35 heures sont trop politiques
trop symbolique à gauche pour que le
gouvernement retire son projet ou même
de l'édulcorant 2 le projet est un
équilibre subtil qui repose
sur 16000 accords d'entreprise y toucher
autrement qu'à la marge c'est prendre le
risque de tout mettre par terre
et puis 3 et surtout paradoxalement les
envolées d'ernest antoine seillière
peuvent aider martine aubry qui est
confrontée à la majorité plurielle un
patronat qui monte en ligne surtout
quand l'opposition est quasi absente on
n'a jamais trouvé mieux pour resserrer
les rangs à gauche
bref fort de cette offensive on dirait
presque cette tentative de
déstabilisation enfin du moins c'est ce
qu'on dira gauche du patronat et
moyennant quelques accommodements sous
forme d'amendement ici ou là le
gouvernement espère bien arrache arraché
l'abstention et même les votes
favorables des verts et des communistes
ce qui pour l'instant n'était pas acquis
merci gérard de toute sa science pour en
apprendre plus sur ce deuxième projet de
loi sur les 35 heures il était inutile
de chercher les quotidiens nationaux ce
matin or le journal la croix puisque la
cgt du livre parisien avait lancé une
journée de grève à perpignan le tribunal
correctionnel vient de condamner à six
mois de prison ferme le vice président
du syndicat des maraîchers des
pyrénées-orientales les faits remontent
à mercredi dernier devant la direction
départementale de l'agriculture à
perpignan la manifestation avait
dégénéré
la décision du tribunal cet après midi
entraîné une très vive colère des
agriculteurs correspondance journée
gaglione avec denis par dano et pascal
pons il était seule dans le box mais il
a payé pour tous un an de prison dont
six mois ferme cinq ans de mise à
l'épreuve avec déchéance de ses droits
civiques
les faits reprochés remontent à mercredi
dernier plusieurs organisations
paysannes occupait alors la direction
départementale de l'agriculture de
perpignan en obtenant trois
fonctionnaires leur libération par les
forces de l'ordre tournaient à
l'affrontement
vite repéré christian soler sont
retrouvés accusés de violences avec arme
sur cinq fonctionnaires de police
c'est une audience qui a largement
dépassé les simples ou et bien sûr qu'en
lequel il était cité nous avons plus
plaidé par les y compris monsieur le
procureur de la république de la
manifestation de la séquestration pour
lequel il n'est pas poursuivi que que
des faits de violence enfin le
commissaire assurément je crois que
c'est la qualification en tout cas que
je peux donner pays paie pour la carence
des pouvoirs publics à essayer de
trouver des solutions
un monde des plus et légumes qui peine
depuis longtemps cette décision de
justice pour eux c'est la rupture de
tout dialogue
un coup de grâce porté à leur profession
l'avocat a déjà annoncé sa décision de
faire appel
dix sept paysans vont se constituer
prisonnier par solidarité aller
christian soler ne comprenant pas qu'un
seul homme paye pour la colère de toute
une profession
une nouvelle fusion industriel et en vue
le fabricant français c'est ita et le
groupe espagnol tabacalera sont en cours
de négociation en vue d'un rapprochement
des deux sociétés
et puis en prévision du passage à l'an
2000 la sncf joue la prudence tous les
trains circulant en france seront
arrêtés pendant 20 minutes
c'est à dire du 31 décembre 23 55 au
premier janvier 0 heure quinze on veut
ainsi éviter toute difficulté technique
lié au fameux bogue informatique environ
85 trains seraient concernés trois
recteurs d'académie viennent de remettre
leur rapport sur la condition
enseignante et les moyens de l'améliorer
il s'agit de proposer de nouvelles
conditions de travail pour les
enseignants des changements pour leur
plan de carrière mais aussi de modifier
l'évaluation de leurs compétences
il s'agit aussi de revaloriser la
situation des chefs d'établissement la
responsabilité de ces derniers est de
plus en plus souvent engagées et leur
rôle ressemble beaucoup à celui d'un
chef d'entreprise habituel exemple avec
ce principal du collège pablo neruda
aulnay-sous-bois rencontré pas frédéric
vion et diane richard
il s'appelle verlaine et il dirige
depuis quatre ans le collège neruda
mais ce qui n'est pas de la poésie ce
sont les 80 professeurs et les 1000
élèves de son établissement un collège
de 42 classes le rôle de patrice
verlaine faire en sorte que tous
tourneront dans cette véritable
entreprise mais si la fonction de
principal réclame des qualités de patron
elle est loin d'entonner toutes les
prérogatives nous n'avons pas tiré le
pouvoir d'un patron dans l'industrie
c'est à dire nous n'avons pas le choix
du personnel nous n'avons pas
possibilité de récuser quelqu'un nous
devons faire avec les personnes qui sont
nommés dans l'établissement quel que
soit leur statut des administratifs aux
professeurs tous sont en effet nommé
selon un système de notes et surtout
d'ancienneté un barème qui pour patrice
verlaine ne prend pas assez en compte la
motivation essentielle pour travailler
dans une zone difficile comme aulnay
résultat le principal se sent souvent
isolé devant sa tâche
d'autant qu'en cas de coup dur il est
seul responsable aux yeux de la loi
lorsqu il y à une demande formulée au
niveau d'un voyage nous sommes
responsables de tout ce qui va se passer
même si ça se passe à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres d'ici lorsque
des élèves utilisent des machines nous
sommes responsables s'ils ont un
accident sur cette machine
donc nous sommes responsables de tout ce
qui se passe dans l'établissement même
au pénal patrice verlaine réclame donc
un statut pour clarifier le rôle des
principaux et pour leur donner les
moyens de sortir leur établissement de
la routine un problème dont les
rédacteurs du rapport publié aujourd'hui
semble avoir pris conscience mais sans
pour l'instant y apporter une réponse
des lycéens eux doivent manifester jeudi
toujours pour réclamer des moyens
supplémentaires dernier exemple en date
d'un couac de rentrée 7 à asnières dans
les hauts-de-seine dans un établissement
d'enseignement adapté qui préparent des
jeunes à des crp ou des projets
professionnels
les enseignants devraient être plus
nombreux qu'ailleurs dans ces cas mais
il en manque toujours cinq ici à
asnières depuis la rentrée et à ce
manque il faut ajouter une pénurie de
surveillants voyez le reportage de
laurence de chef avec philippe josselin
masson 300 comme elisabeth à se
retrouver cet après midi livrés à eux
mêmes il est 13 heures certains rentrent
directement chez eux les autres
traîneront sûrement centre ville ce midi
les élèves n'étaient pas surpris de la
décision de leur professeur d'arrêter
les cours parce c'est après cette année
c'est pas possible il nous faut des
preuves des profs comme dessin technique
n'a pas trop de déchets techniques et
pratiques de transferts brumath et ses
favoris
un manque de profs mais aussi de
surveillants deux seulement pour 300
élèves c'est insuffisant pour limiter
les risques seules les toilettes des
garçons restent ouvertes
son rayon un établissement pas tout à
fait comme les autres
l'enseignement est adapté aux élèves en
difficulté scolaire l'encadrement doit y
être plus important qu'ailleurs pour des
classes plus légère douze élèves maximum
des années que ça dure c'est rentrée des
enseignants dans notre établissement
c'est vraiment pas possible parce qu'on
a vraiment une relation difficile ils
demandent plus d'attention des véhicules
le pire c'est qu'on nous dit vous avez
été gentils vous avez commencé pendant
un mois un mois et demi continuez comme
ça vous allez voir s'allonger aussi on
bouge pas on voit que rien ne s'arrange
rien ne bouge cet après midi une
délégation d'enseignants a été reçue à
l'inspection académique
on leur a promis le recrutement des cinq
professeurs manquant pour le reste pas
de réponse
ils décideront demain matin d'accueillir
ou pas leurs élèves en cours
première visite d'état depuis 1986
depuis 86 ans pardon pour un président
de la république française en espagne un
déplacement avec un temps fort demain
puisque monsieur chirac s'exprimera
devant les députés espagnols
le président a appelé aujourd'hui à
madrid alors qu'on le voit ici posé en
compagnie du roi juan carlos à se battre
résolument en faveur de l'exception
culturelle
ici en compagnie du premier ministre
monsieur asnar en autriche à l'issue des
élections législatives une période
d'instabilité politique pourrait
s'ouvrir c'est le résultat du parti de
la liberté de jörg haider qui suscite
plus d'embarras voire d'inquiétude
embarras des sociaux-démocrates au
pouvoir avec leurs alliés et
conservateurs et inquiétude car ce parti
de la liberté qui a recueilli environ
27% des suffrages est ouvertement
d'extrême droite populiste est favorable
rejet de toute immigration reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux olivier lerner et
york and gross qui y khayder a changé de
statut
il fait désormais partie des grands il
estimera son devoir accompli en grande
partie quand il arrivera au gouvernement
sur le devant de la scène il est
brillant capable d'écouter et
d'expliquer à lui tout seul il a porté
son parti de 5 à 27 % en l'espace de dix
ans durant cette campagne il s'est
appuyé sur deux slogans qui sont d'abord
l'autriche halte à l'immigration la
tradition la patrie la fierté tels sont
les mots clés de son vocabulaire
l'immigration la xénophobie ce n'est pas
pour nous le sujet principal c'est
souvent monté en épingle par les médias
parce que c'est un sujet tabou dans la
société
nous on nous taxe de xénophobie ouverte
mais on est contre le libéralisme de
gauche qui laisse les frontières
ouvertes à tous ce n'est pas l'extrême
droite ça n'est pas populiste
on veut toujours nous ranger dans cette
catégorie sur internet son programme
s'étend sur 55 pages chapitre politique
familiale on lit hausse des allocations
oui mais exclusivement pour les
autrichiens chapitre immigration les
étrangers au chômage dehors c'est la
rampe et l'autriche pour le disais qu'on
m'avait jamais ensemble chez pense c'est
une chance et une crise dans le système
politique a péché mais dans cette crise
il ya des solutions avec des nouveaux
approche avec l'agencement et la basse
pour la démocratie york rider avec un
pompier coiffé d'un casque de l'armée
allemande la fiche n'est pas passé
inaperçu autre poignée de main remarquée
avec le chancelier cette fois hier soir
pas question de cohabitation entre les
deux hommes mais ryder est en position
de force
à partir de maintenant dans sa région la
carinthie située dans le sud du pays
horkheimer atteint des sommets avec près
de 44% des voix quasiment un électeur
sur deux a donc voté pour cet homme qui
a réussi le tour de force d'incarner le
changement avec un programme
nationaliste proche du national
socialisme des années 30
à berlin plus d'une centaine de tombes
ont été profanées ces derniers jours
dans le cimetière de vice en zee qui
abrite 115 mille tombes de juifs les
profanations n'ont pas été revendiqués
aucun slogan antisémite n'a été laissée
sur ces tombes profanées l'armée russe
avant sans territoire tchétchène elle se
trouverait à moins de 20 km de la
capitale grozny et les combats seraient
très violente retrouve fédéral et forces
tchétchènes 64 soldats russes auraient
été tués dans les dernières 24 heures
non loin de la frontière tchétchène au
daguestan dans le village de karachi ce
que l'on appelle les terroristes et
islamistes s'expose ouvertement c'est
l'un des deux villages détenus parce que
moscou désigne comme les principaux
auteurs de la rébellion
voici un document tourné dans ce village
avec les commentaires de gilles rabin et
franck brisset ils jouent à la guerre
comme le font tous les fils de
montagnards du daguestan sans savoir que
la guerre va les rattraper
parce qu'ils habitent à karachi un des
deux villages proclamé territoire
islamique et fief de la charia
le seul endroit de russie où l'on
pouvait voir des femmes porter la robe
le foulard et le voile noir des
musulmanes du moyen-orient à karachi
depuis deux ans la seule loi c'est celle
du coran instauré par de véritables
missionnaire d'islamistes les fameux
wahhabite derrière lesquels le kremlin
voit la main du terrorisme international
l'islam on va instaurer en russie il est
aussi en amérique et en angleterre
partout ces images ont été tournées
début septembre quelques heures avant
que le kremlin décide d'en finir avec
ces voix a vite il tolérait pourtant
depuis deux ans
la reconquête de camara qui a duré plus
de deux semaines
et quand le représentant du gouvernement
local vient en tournée d'inspection
c'est avec son fils de 11 ans si on
avait rétabli l'ordre dès le départ n'y
aurait pas eu autant de victimes il y
autant de maisons détruites
c'est aussi notre fou pour cette visite
de propagande sur le front le fils
malgré ses 11 ans aura la permission
d'essayer de tirs au canon
la semaine dernière la mary ça finit par
vaincre ce qu'elle appelait le péril
oued la paix est revenue sur le village
rebelles de camara chi et c'est la paix
des cimetières n'est pas de nous des
wahhabites mais déjà en attaque pourquoi
personne n osait on n'a plus rien il
fait froid l'hiver approche et on a plus
de maison les web it s'était préparé à
une attaque et de longue date ils
disposaient des armes les plus modernes
des armes russes il avait acheté des
armes partout c'était possible y compris
dans des unités militaires russes le
village était défendue par plusieurs
bunkers creusé dans la montagne
non j'ai dormi ici il ya encore des
concerne et là bas regardez c'est
l'entrée d'un autre boulot caire les
soldats de l'armée russe s'installe pour
ce qu'ils pensent être une longue guerre
sans illusion sur le résultat ni sur les
vrais enjeux
tout ce qui se passe ici je vous le jure
et je le dis sans gêne et sans réfléchir
tout ça c'est pour cacher les affaires
du kremlin et de boris
sur les hauteurs la canonnade et les
bombardements continus mais cette fois
ci au delà de la frontière sur la
tchétchénie lors de la première guerre
96 les combattants tchétchènes ont
montré qu'ils pouvaient rester maîtres
de leur montagne il avait vaincu l'armée
la grande russie à belgrade ce matin le
chef du principal parti de l'opposition
serbe vuk draskovic qui vient d'échapper
à un accident de voiture qualifier
celui-ci d'attentât et vue grâce qu'aux
geeks donne des détails qui semblent
impliqués sans le nommer le pouvoir la
seule vue des véhicules accidentés est
édifiante
reportage de nos envies spéciaux gerra
griesbeck et jean-françois hoffman ce
sont les dernières images de la voiture
de vuk draskovic son beau frère est mort
à côté de lui
l'autre voiture ou ses trois gardes du
corps ont été tués
entièrement brûlé enfin le camion qui
les a heurté volontairement ou non
le chauffeur aurait été arrêté mais les
faits sont encore troubles
c'est un attentat a dit vous grâce kovic
une partie de la presse s'en est fait
écho la mort du beau-frère de vous grâce
kovic est un coup dur pour son parti
weiss l hymne boscovich était au centre
des circuits financiers de belgrade
l'homme supervisait à la mairie les
travaux publics et privés de la capitale
cette affaire va peut être rapproché les
deux oppositions celles qui descendent
dans la rue tous les jours et celles
regroupées autour de vous grâce kovic
hier au soir ils étaient encore des
milliers à défiler dans les rues plus
nombreux en province qu'à belgrade
la police était très présente mais il
n'y a pas eu d'incident
l'avocat de vuk draskovic qui est aussi
un des dirigeants de son parti a dit
publiquement qu'il était partisan d'un
rapprochement entre les deux oppositions
la seule solution qu'en gagnant services
et la coalition entre tous les partis
d'opposition qui pourrait alors très
facilement faire tomber milosevic entre
nous n'avons que des divergences tac
cette déclaration réjouit l'opposition
qui entame sa troisième semaine de
marche contre le régime
j'espère bien que vos brevets rejoindre
l'opposition et avec tous les autres
travailler contre le mélange activement
j'ai l'impression que c'est un attentat
ou c'est un accident de voiture c'est
difficile à dire ce moment parce qu'on
ne sait pas les détails dans ce pays
tout est possible avec mme eroshevich
vous ne savez jamais la force du
président milosevic c'est la division de
l'opposition et vuk draskovic est devenu
une pièce maîtresse sur l'échiquier
politique
alors l'homme est imprévisible
spécialiste des coups d'éclat opposant
éclipse mais son accident d'hier
pourrait le faire basculer dans le camp
de ceux qui réclament la démission du
président yougoslave en france à
bordeaux la cour d'assises de la gironde
s'est déclarée incompétente pour statuer
sur la demande de dispense de placement
en détention déposé par les avocats de
maurice papon l'examen du pourvoi en
cassation de maurice papon doit avoir dû
le 21 août prochain et selon le voit
maurice papon devrait être en détention
jour là mais la cour d'assisses est donc
déclarée incompétente pour le décider
plainte devant le tribunal de grande
instance de marseille déposée par le
directeur de la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie de nantes c'est une
action peu banal puisqu'il s'agit
d'obtenir de l'olympique de marseille et
de l'un de ses joueurs
le remboursement de frais médicaux
occasionnés par le footballeur
marseillais patrick blondeau à yves
deroff joueur du fc nantes
l'explication julien erichot c'était
l'ultime journée du championnat de
france de football de la saison passée
le marseillais patrick blondeau brise en
un geste la carrière du joueur nantais
yves deroff double fracture tibia péroné
sur le terrain blondeau et comme dans un
premier temps d'un carton jaune puis la
ligue le suspens finalement pour un mois
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie de nantes
de lui réclamer des comptes
les soins prodigués aux nantais de rohff
devrait atteindre 600 mille francs
le directeur de la caisse a donc décidé
de réclamer le remboursement des sommes
à patrick blondeau et à l'olympique de
marseille
du moins leur assurance respectives ça
se fait dans tous les domaines les
domaines de les accidents circulation
des accidents domestiques des accidents
de 12 hors des loques iaa tiers
responsable bien entendu et en matière
de football je ne se fait pas ça ne
s'est pas fait même lorsque le tiers est
responsable est clairement identifié à
marseille on s'étonne de cette démarche
très inhabituelle dans le milieu du
football
des accidents comme celui ci dit là bas
sont malheureusement possible sur des
terrains de sport les dirigeants
marseillais et craignent une
multiplication des procédures
si ces choses là commence à être fait
bon ça peut être ça peut être assez
assez grave puisque il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de matchs de football en france
quand même tout le week-end et a
systématiquement ça pourrait devenir
beaucoup beaucoup de cas et dans golliot
juridique la demande de la sécurité
sociale sera examiné prochainement par
un tribunal de grande instance
en attendant yves d'europe n'a toujours
pas repris l'entraînement avec ses
coéquipiers nantais en judo david
douillet renonce aux championnats du
monde qui débuteront le 7 octobre
prochain birmingham en angleterre
le 4 août le championnat elle souffre en
effet du dos il a préféré déclarer
forfait il reporte ses espoirs sur les
jeux olympiques de sydney l'année
prochaine le peintre bernard buffet
s'est donné la mort cet après-midi dans
sa propriété de tourtour dans le var il
était âgé de 71 ans il vivait plutôt
isolé peu ménagé par les critiques et
les spécialistes ces oeuvres très
nombreuses très reconnaissables par
leurs traits sont pourtant connus et
détenus dans le monde entier évocation
de bernard buffet par georges big ou
retirer à tout retour en haute provence
bernard buffet ne venaient plus à paris
que pour ce vernissage annuel en octobre
en février il peignait énormément
tout paris qui l'avait tant fréquenté ne
l'intéressé plus les critiques qui lui
avaient donné leur prix en 1948 il
n'avait pas 20 ans le méprise est
aujourd'hui et pourtant il était à
l'étranger
le plus connu des peintres français le
musée de l'ermitage à saint pétersbourg
l'avait accueilli avec chaleur
ce clown a fait le tour du monde les
posters se sont vendus par milliers le
style de bernard buffet un
expressionnisme aux personnages
fortement cernés de noir s'est affirmé
dès sa sortie des beaux-arts en 1949
sa peinture porte la marque des années
de guerre plus tard sa palette
s'éclaircit rare mais locle et le noir
demeureront c'est ton majeur vous avez
l'impression d'être un vieux sage
alors je suis pas un ange peut toujours
changer charges est en jeu sachant que
cruz et critique français vous boude les
japonais vous adore pourquoi je ne sais
pas je suis très fier au but est à
nouveau
l'humour un peu cynique de bernard
buffet
masque une déchirure profonde allez-vous
la fois à oui je croyais en échange
l'état choqué
bernard commence à travailler à 6h30
18h45 au concert on prend le petit
déjeuner vivait à l'atelier moi je
descends j'écris un peu et puis je
m'occupe du domaine en tous cas à faire
ici quelque chose se préparait cet été
dans la quiétude et dans le secret il
pensait à sa prochaine exposition thème
choisi la mort
les nouvelles aventures d'eddy mitchell
help us par memphis san jose 6 la
nouvelle orléans on retrouve le rocare
le crooner l'homme des mélodies qui vous
font prendre la route j'ai quelques
questions à lui poser mais voici
maintenant quelques instants de l'un des
titres contenus d'un nouvel album d'eddy
mitchell tourner homme de paille
le blanc
je bats
je parle là
mange pas des yeux
on
je suis
je
mal
non
alors s'ils voulaient en savoir plus
c'est le cd qui viennent qui ont sorti
un retour un peu de nostalgie memphis un
geste de leurre les ans est votre
parcours à vous c'est quand même pas
forcément disons que ça correspond
surtout je vais aux chansons aux
chansons donc à l'issue de l'écriture de
chaque chanson avec mon compositeur avec
pierre paillé en lice on se disait où
est ce qu'on va la faire bon celle ci
allait ait même blouse donc il faut la
faire à memphis celle ci c'est une
chanson qui appelle les cordes ou temps
de faire dans ce lieu mythique qu'est
capitol records à los angeles et puis y
ait des gens sont un peu plus funky donc
ce sera amusant d'essayer de remuer
lorient et là j'ai lu quelque part que
vous écrivez dans votre taille joue même
pas ce que vous vous trouvez pas
d'auteur il n'ya pas d'auteur pour faire
eddy mitchell pour faire le style eddy
mitchell weeds on sait enfin ce un
hasard c'est à dire que chaque fois
qu'on me
propose des chansons la plupart du temps
c'est déjà des chansons tu en fasses un
remake ou c'est vous c'est un pas un
plagiat mesure ça ressemble à une
chanson que j'ai déjà fait donc c'est
pas la peine alors je dis c'est site
très mélodique on retrouve vraiment une
tradition eddy mitchell vous vous avez
envie d'entretenir sa vous n'êtes pas
envie d'explorer d'autres secteurs j'ai
pas les verts vers la salsa les rythmes
africains et vous allez vous voulez
rester toujours dans ce style c'est pas
vouloir se savoir faut essayer de faire
ce qu'on s'est fait dix ans que je peux
pas vous faire du rail
enfin même sur l attelage j'ai pas le
temps d'ailleurs j'aurais pas le faire
j'aurais pas le faire même si j'aime ça
même s'ils s'amusent on n'en faut
forrest et des gens honnêtes vrai donc
je sais pas être autrement alors c'est
vrai nous rajeunir la première chanson
c'était en 1960 comme à si vous trouvez
toujours le désir de faire une chanson
de l'écrire de remonter sur scène pour
une tournée que vous allez faire vous
allez être à bercy à partir du 25
janvier prochain comment vous trouvez ça
parce que ces formules ne faut pas se
raconter l'histoire c'est ça un métier
quand même où on est très très gâté on
n'était pas nombreux et de gâter mes
fait partie de ces élus donc je vais pas
cracher dans la soupe bien de savoir que
bon je vais retrouver un public à partir
de janvier sur scène bon bah c'est quand
même formidable de savoir surtout que
cdc des gens qui ont envie de me voir
être s'amuser avec moi donc c'est bien
bien entendu quelque chose de l'unique
alors à écouter avec vous plaisir vos
chansons on peut se demander s'il ya pas
beaucoup de nostalgie chez vous et une
distance ainsi nice en forme vous l'a
déjà dit souvent une sorte de deux
regards un peu distant sur les choses de
la vie
nostalgie peut-être pas beaucoup mes
distances sur distance c'est sûr parce
que si on prend tous au pied de la
lettre on s'emmêle dans la tête comme
viennent de le faire non pas les bus et
donc il vaut mieux pas passer de ce côté
là il ya des titres d'un rush a songé à
prendre que vous avez répondu j'ai des
goûts simples ce titre d'une des
chansons vous avez des goûts simples
oui mais je me calmer
golden boy c'est vraiment pas votre truc
c'est non non c'est pas que ce soit pas
mon truc c'est certain mais un métier
grave dans la mesure où effectivement on
n'a pas de vie on n'a pas dit parce que
parce que faut avoir une pendule avec
soit perpétuellement pour être alors de
tournon vous avez bien faire la sienne
dormir pendant votre temps boire un coup
oui j'ai ouï oui il faut faire tout seul
oui je suppose que j'aime pas les gens
heureux
autre titre ça alors ça c'est la
moquerie totale sinon oui mais ça se
joue ici année le bonheur est bien des
choses rien non mais vous avez dans ça
c'est une chanson qui s'adresse à à des
gens prêts spéciaux qui sont du
californien c'est pour ça tu es a pu
cesser les gens qu'on rencontre dans la
rue ont toujours des étoiles dans les
dents qu'on les filles ont des baucus a
fait semblant de leçons bronzée au cas
je suis bien et tu vas bien aujourd'hui
au dessus tu es mignonne tu sais je
t'aime
et si vous dites pas malheur moi je vais
pas bien elle change de trottoir
donc c'est ça c'est ce genre qui sont
puis enfin t'es qu'un joueur vous êtes
joueur non budgétés et qu'un jour je le
mets dans la vie naturellement vous
aimez bien le jeu ah oui oui bien sûr
j'avoue ça mais même ça fait partie du
métier de la fonction des usages du
chanteur ou de l'acteur alors le cd qui
sort mais le cinéma quand est ce qu on
vous revoit veux pour mon nom j'ai pas
le temps j'ai faut le temps je sais pas
j'espère que ce jour mettre ça dans un
an
mais voilà la fin de cette édition je
rappelle les informations que nous avons
développées tout d'abord l'est
manifestation celle des patrons contre
les 35 heures ils étaient plus de 20000
au palais des sports à paris contre la
loi aubry
une manifestation à l'appel de la cgt
étaient plusieurs milliers en france et
à paris où un extension de la loi avril
le débat parlementaire sur le second
projet de loi aura lieu demain puis
enfin on a appris cet après midi que
bernard buffet s'était donné la mort le
peintre qui vivait retiré dans le var
laisse une oeuvre populaire très
importante il avait 71 ans
la météo c'est dans quelques instants et
nathalie rihouet puis la première de
quelle histoire le magazine présenté par
william leymergie où l'on retrouvera des
alsaciens au texas mais aussi saint
tropez une certaine angèle regardez bien
à 23h10 argent public avec sylvain attal
e et angèle vous l'avez connu e et puis
michel boujenah avec quotidien à thala 0
heures 20 le dernier journal vous sera
présentée par laurence ostolaza suivi de
musique au coeur présenté par eve
ruggieri une amie d'eddy mitchell et
pour garder désormais lundi sur
l'antenne de l'actualité musicale de la
rentrée demain 7 en cinq ans dans le cas
du rite et gérard morin recevra la
madeleine président de démocratie
libérale et puis à 13h vous trouverez
quelques esther et rachid arhab à demain
20h bonsoir